with us now from Phoenix is Rick Davis
who was one of Senator McCain's closest
confidants he was a longtime aide who
served as national campaign manager
both times McCain ran for president he
was with the McCain family this past
weekend Rick good to see you let's start
first with I know you were with the
McCain family recently what was it like
to be with him in his final days well it
was a great pleasure for me to be
counted as one of the family over the
last week you know we've been together
almost since these kids were born and
and to have spent a lot of time over the
last six months in and out of their
beautiful place in Sedona with the
family with Cindy and and the kids was
was probably the greatest opportunity in
my life to sort of see closure with what
has been the greatest wildest adventure
I think in anybody's history so it was
it was really wonderful to be included I
really appreciate it as as heartbreaking
as it was
I can't imagine wanting to be anywhere
else what is the best way that we could
honor and pay tribute to him Rick as
someone who knew him well well Gail I I
think yesterday was great testament to
what that tribute is looking like I
don't think I've ever seen a Sunday you
know where there was only one report and
that was all about John McCain he would
love that
I mean he loved the media he felt really
strongly about having total access to
all of you and as a as a political
strategist for him for over 20 years
that was a nightmare for me most of the
time but he would have loved it he would
have absolutely loved it and I don't
think he would have spent two minutes
away from the television set watching
all the coverage it was just glorifying
and around the world I mean every media
outlet in every country in every capital
you know spent the day talking about
John McCain and that
was really a special thing Rick one of
his colleagues said yesterday they were
we're losing John McCain right when we
need him the most which may account for
the extraordinary outpouring of
affection from from both sides and you
get the sense from from John Dickerson's
piece that that John McCain was was kind
of aware of that in his last year did
you get that sense yeah I mean a lot of
John's life was spent in the arena I
mean he was the man in the arena he
loved it harder it was the better he
liked it and and I think it was a bit of
a bittersweet situation for him for the
last six months he was in a beautiful
place rented by his family fighting you
know cancer and every day wishing he was
in the well of that Senate trying to
make America a better place and he had
great opportunities in some of the
speeches in the last year to really use
the opportunity to crystallize some of
those messages and I'm so proud that he
was able to do that you know in
Philadelphia at the mellah Freedom Award
and in Annapolis the places he really
loved and Rick Senator McCain requested
that both former presidents Barack Obama
and George W Bush speak and deliver
eulogies at his funeral these were the
two men that kept him from the
presidency why did he want them to
eulogize him I think it's it's a very
practical thing
John Dickerson alluded to it when he
tells these stories and he lives his
life you know there are things he
experienced himself right it's not just
somebody else's story that's a message
to the people it's his life story and
his life story is even in defeat he
found ways to working with people like
George Bush and Barack Obama and in a
world that this turn you know red and
blue and nothing in between
even as he planned his own funeral he
felt very strongly that he wanted to
have these two individuals who he grew
to respect and work with closely to try
and accomplish important things for the
country in the world to be present
his and his funeral and the decision not
to the family's decision not to include
President Trump at the funeral too it
also says something does it not well we
really want to focus on the positive
aspects of John's life and I'd prefer
not to get into any of that at this
point all right Rick Dave is totally
understand that thank you very much for
joining us